tu connais personnellement la famille de
Lindsay alors ma conjointe est une amie
d'enfance de Corentin Corentin qui est
le parrain de l'Insee nous a rapporté
premièrement le drame on était touché et
ensuite quand il nous a raconté les
circonstances on a cru que c'était un
film Netflix mais c'était la réalité
c'est fou et quand j'ai parlé avec Betty
et Corentin donc Bettina Armand qui m'a
demandé de
d'essayer de d'en parler parce qu'il y
avait un simple article dans un journal
local là j'ai pris mon téléphone et j'ai
essayé de parler à mon audience pour
qu'on puisse faire effet boule de neige
et c'est ce qui s'est passé après moi je
veux aucune aucune flagornerie moi j'ai
fait ça bien sûr
c'est des proches de ma conjointe mais
voilà moi après quand j'entends pas une
vieille dire que c'est un échec alors
justement on va en parler de paper
Ndiaye parce que vous avez été reçu par
paper Ndiaye aujourd'hui mettre de
Buisson va en parler dans un instant
vous avez donné avec la famille de
Linkedin conférence de presse un jeudi
dernier la maman l'Insee a annoncé
qu'elle avait reçu aucun courrier de la
part du gouvernement depuis le décès de
sa fille regardez on n'a pas été aidé on
a été lâché complètement aucun soutien
ni avant ni pendant ni après l'Insee un
moment elle était au collège
et elle demandait de l'aide au directeur
le directeur lui a carrément dit écoute
tu m'embêtes avec tes bêtises on a pas
que ça à faire ça reste entre nous il
lui a totalement dit ça je remercie
d'ailleurs toutes les personnes qui nous
soutiennent parce que vous êtes ma force
aujourd'hui
sans vous je ne serai pas là
je sais même pas où je serai d'ailleurs
mais
je
sais plus elle me manque
qui je fais de gros bisous tu as la
chance de rencontrer qui est quelqu'un
de formidable et qui est vraiment elle
est à terre je fais d'énormes bisous et
donc elle dit bien qu'elle a eu aucun
courrier ni aucune nouvelle de la part
du gouvernement pourtant le ministre de
l'Éducation PAP and I annoncé avant
juste avant sur BFM qu'il avait contacté
la famille
d'un échec collectif il y a une enquête
judiciaire qui a été lancée bien entendu
je comprends les cris du cœur des
parents je comprends l'émotion elle est
aussi la mienne nous avons beaucoup
avancé en matière de harcèlement et nous
avons encore du chemin à parcourir et
donc je tirerai les leçons
voilà donc il a pas contacté la famille
excusez-moi
monsieur le ministre mais
c'est pour aller sur un plateau télé
pour dire n'importe quoi c'est vaut
mieux ne rien dire excusez-moi de vous
dire ça il a quand même dit qu'il a pas
réussi à appeler la famille plutôt parce
qu'il n'a pas trouvé de numéro ben nous
on l'a trouvé
que c'est un immense manque de respect
par les déchets parce que un échec c'est
quand son enfant rate son brevet l'Insee
elle aura jamais la chance de passer le
brevet donc il faut vraiment qu'il se
remette en question et là quand il dit
qu'ils se sont dépassés qui peut rien
faire pour le harcèlement scolaire
moi j'ai en tant enfin je pense que tous
les parents de France se sont en danger
vraiment ah bah c'est sûr justement
alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé mettre
alors vous avez été voir donc le
ministre de l'Éducation qu'est-ce que
vous a dit d'abord merci de me recevoir
pourtant de parler de ce sujet qui
touche 10 % des élèves des collégiens
des lycéens partout en France c'est une
catastrophe c'est franchement c'est un
fléau contre lequel personne ne se bat
j'étais attentif à ce que vous avez dit
quand vous avez reçu les parents la
semaine dernière les parents de Maelys
que je représente aussi et ce qui est
catastrophique c'est que personne
personne ne semble prendre la mesure de
la gravité du problème je vous jure
c'est le sort du ministère et et rien de
concret n'a été apporté la prise de
conscience apparaît comme d'habitude la
prise de conscience elle paraît tout à
fait limitée aucune mesure concrète ne
va être mise en place pour sensibiliser
les plus jeunes à l'école primaire au
collège beaucoup plus grave beaucoup
plus grave par rapport aux
cyber-harcèlement le ministre m'a confié
que l'État français aujourd'hui et si
pas là pour faire du buzz ou quoi que ce
soit était totalement incapable
d'enrayer les le fléau du cy pas
seulement vis-à-vis des réseaux sociaux
c'est à dire que ils sont tenus à une
obligation de modération par rapport à
des propos illicites haineux violents
ils ne peuvent rien faire c'est ce qui
m'a été dit à une heure à peine en
sortant de du ministère de l'Éducation
nationale donc c'est assez sidérant de
voir que l'État est très accueillant
très vous avez des enfants qui sont
victimes peut-être un jour vous
n'importe qui de cyber-harcèlement
personne ne peut rien faire ni l'État ni
la police ni le collège ni l'Académie
après ce qui se passe c'est qu'il y a
des drames parce que on va pas se mentir
un père un peu nerveux il se passe ça
pour son fils on sait très bien on
s'affiche ça va dégénérer il va se faire
vie il va se faire
justifier lui-même et après qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire on va dire bah oui
forcément le gouvernement ne peut rien
faire la police ils ont pas les moyens
les pauvres ils font ce qu'ils veulent
mais ils ont pas les moyens donc au bout
d'un moment moi que vous revenez du
ministère de l'Éducation et que nous
disiez ils n'ont pas de solution et ils
sont de rien ils sont dépassés ils sont
dépassés par et je vais vous dire moi
vous pouvez pas savoir ce weekend
le nombre de messages et de photos que
j'ai reçues de personnes qui me disaient
que leur fille ou leur travail étaient
victimes de harcèlement dans toutes ces
jolies c'est un truc de fou dans tous
les collèges famille abandonné qui
appelle à l'aide à la police le collège
l'Académie personne ne leur répond et le
retourne le dos et le pire ce qui se
passe c'est que dans dans les collèges
dans les lycée ils ont tellement peur
d'avoir une mauvaise d'être mal noté de
faire un mauvais buzz euh exactement
et garder l’harceleur c'est c'est ce qui
ressort c'est exactement
systématiquement
c'est ce qu'on a vu dans tous les
témoignages qu'on a vu dans cette
émission ils veulent pas prendre du
risque parce qu'ils veulent pas qu'on
parle de par rapport à du harcèlement
donc ils disent on va isoler l'enfant
donc qui a été qui a été harcelé et
c'est lui à chaque fois qu'il se
retrouve obligé de changer de collège
changer de vie moi j'aimerais dire
ça me paraît important
ça a vraiment cristallisé un basculement
dans une nouvelle aire qui est
totalement délirante c'est-à-dire que la
mort de l'Insee n'a pas suffi à mettre
un terme aux déchaînement et de violence
sur les réseaux sociaux sa mémoire
continue d'être souillée on a plus
aucune limite dans ce degré de violence
et un deuxième élément qui me paraît
fondamental et qui était assez
significatif de de l'état d'esprit de
certains membres de l'éducation
nationale aucun professeur du collège
n'a appelé à la mère n'a écrit à la mer
n'a participé à la marche blanche ou il
allait voir après le décès ni le
principal du collège ni aucun professeur
c'est à mépris absolu pour la vie
humaine et c'est assez sidérant là aussi
alors le ministre de l'Éducation t'as
pas une vieille après trois semaines
donc après le décès de l'Insee a donc
reçu aujourd'hui les parents ainsi que
vous juste dites nous on a envie de
savoir il vous a dit quoi vous arrivez
vous dit quoi je vais relayer les propos
des pas l'impression des parents qui
considèrent que il y a eu certaines
excuses certes mais qui manquait de
sincérité
qui manquait de profondeur une absence
totale de
prise de conscience de prise de
conscience forte qui nécessite une
action réelle et concrète donc rien de
concret en fait donc il vous a dit quoi
je vais faire quoi et vous a dit je vais
voir quand même le le directeur de
l'établissement les résultats de
l'enquête d'administrative qui avait été
lancé ce qui paraît normal mais là les
faits sont tellement énormes si vous
voulez qu'il y a pas attendre dénoncer
le comportement totalement anormal du
responsable du collège de l'Académie et
même des policiers qui ont pris la
plainte pénale qui avait tous les
éléments la lettre de suicide le dossier
médical qui n'ont rien qu'une jeune
fille qui s'est donné la mort je suis
désolé déjà tu reçois le gars qui gère
le collège je lui rassois le proviseur
tu dis qu'est-ce qui se passe est-ce
qu'il y a un vrai vrai problème dans
dans le dans le collège ce qui s'est
c'est pas possible en fait il n'en sais
rien déjà il a attendu trois semaines
avant de contacter la famille ou d'aller
les voir la moindre des choses c'était
de partager quelques mots de compassion
et puis et puis non malheureusement rien
on parle de sortie
bien sûr mais pourquoi mais mais elle a
pas elle a pas elle a pas complètement
torche désolé
mais pourquoi peut-être que Géraldine il
y a eu un meurt il y a eu un mort il y a
un mort vous êtes fous quoi bien sûr
je trouve complètement mais pas du tout
à la hauteur de l'événement et donc je
pense qu'il pourrait présenter sa
démission
que vous dites pas une bêtise a eu
beaucoup de courage en écrivant cette
lettre et malheureusement en se donnant
la mort et je trouve que lui il devrait
aussi avoir un petit peu de courage en
disant que j'ai il n'a pas été à la
hauteur de ce qui s'est passé
premièrement je pense qu'il aurait dû
virer directement le principal parce que
le principal pour moi ça n'engage que
moi à du sang sur les mains quand tu as
un élève vient dans son bureau lui dit
qu'il est au bout du rouleau qu'il a que
13 ans et qui pense à la mort lui lui
dit pas trop ébruiter l'affaire on va
essayer de le faire entre nous n'en
parlez pas pour moi tout ce qui se passe
après c'est grave il faut qu'il soit
radié de l'éducation nationale faut que
les élèves soient radis à l'éducation
nationale qu'elle puisse plus jamais
mettre les pieds dans un établissement
gratuit auprès des Français il faut tout
de suite que les sanctions soient faites
là j'ai l'impression d'écouter Dalida
paroles il y a aucune sanction qui a été
faite aujourd'hui il ne fait rien donc
voilà il y a pas que lui alors qu'est-ce
qui s'est la plupart des de nombreuses
personnes étaient parfaitement informées
la situation de la détresse dans
laquelle l'Insee était plong
on nous a parlé d'une promotion même ah
oui alors à vérifier
qu'on voit la réaction des départs de
l'Insee qu'on va libérer revouler le
train
parce que regarder merci
vraiment affecté par la situation de
notre fille maintenant on attend au
niveau des actes on a vidé monsieur le
ministre à participer à la marche
blanche on espère qu'il viendra qui
viendra qui sera présent et pour nous
c'est pas suffisant par rapport au
contenu du dialogue il nous a attendu la
main nous c'est comme on a dit avec ma
femme
on est content entre guillemets mais on
aurait aimé un peu plus un peu plus
François il est venu nous voir il était
là
et Cédric François il est il m'a dit
Cyril on est lâché
pas le coeur à mettre une cravate et à
mettre une une chemise vous avez vu son
billet pour aller voir le ministre etc
non mais je vous jure c'est hyper
touchant
parce que moi pour moi on les a pas
respecté mais lui il respecte quand même
il est alimenté est-ce que tu as le cœur
à mettre une cravate à mettre une
chemise moi je vais te dire tu as perdu
c'est vrai tu as ta belle-fille qui
était avec ta élevé qui qui se retrouve
qui t'a perdu tu vas aller voir le
ministre tu regardes même voilà et Betty
aussi elle s'est habillée pour un mois
et demi franchement je vous dis ce sont
des gens je les ai vu ils sont ils sont
incroyables ils sont incroyables c'est
vraiment sans histoire ils veulent juste
voilà c'est plusieurs jours avec Betty
elle est incroyable et François aussi
François c'est extraordinaire
elle m'a raconté comment elle a essayé
de la réanimer franchement
ça me brise ça me brise parce que je me
dis que elle a tout fait elle a appelé
tout le monde elle a essayé de parler à
tout le monde à la crier à la place de
sa fille et aujourd'hui elle se retrouve
à mettre une petite chaise à côté de sa
tombe pour
pour parler avec elle franchement moi à
la place des responsables j'aurais honte
franchement
il y a deux choses qui me frappent moi
c'est le ministre qui reçoit la famille
trois semaines après il est en retard
c'est terrible et je trouve qu'il n'y a
aucune empathie il y a rien il y a pas
de de l'avocat parlé de profondeur mais
je trouve que maintenant il y a même pas
de considération il y a même pas
d'émotion on dirait un techno qui parle
d'une affaire administrative c'est
terrible et la deuxième chose qui me qui
me frappe pour faire écho à ce que dire
à mousse et qu'on a l'impression que
l'institution éducation nationale c'est
comme l'armée avant la Grande-Motte il
se couvre les uns les autres il y a
personne qui est capable de dire j'ai
fait une faute on parle de
responsabilité collective ça ne veut
rien dire responsabilité collective ça
veut dire il y aura pas de responsable
personne n'est capable de dire on a
fauté voilà ce qu'il faut faire c'est
terrible parce que comme vous le disiez
s'il y a pas une prise de conscience au
niveau ministériel et même sans doute
que maintenant le ministre de
l'éducation nationale est discrédité et
dépassé ça va recommencer Cyril et vous
avez des témoignages il faut mettre un
terme à ce harcèlement qui tue des
enfants et qui les brise il est
insoutenable c'est aujourd'hui elle
représente tous les enfants harcelés de
France tous et c'est pas aux enfants qui
sont harcelés de fuir c'est aux
harceleurs de fuir parce que j'en
entends dire oui mais pourquoi vous
l'avez pas changé d'école c'est pas eux
d'avoir honte c'est à ceux qui n'ont
absolument qui continuent de dire qu'ils
vont se pisser sur ça tombe tu voulais
venir à son enterrement qui continue
d'envoyer des messages à Miley sans lui
disant c'est ton tour
qui l'ont motivé à faire ce geste parce
qu'il faut savoir que les circonstances
dans laquelle elle est décédée c'est eux
qui lui ont décrit au millimètre près
comment les faire c'est ça ça c'est ça
c'est ça qui est important c'est eux qui
lui ont dit rejoins ton père de la même
manière dont il est mort
c'est eux qui lui ont dit vas-y tu es
qu'une tu mérites que ça et elle
avait juste besoin de repos et elle a
choisi de repos éternel donc là
aujourd'hui si ça bouge pas c'est
maintenant ou jamais sinon on pourra pas
faire semblant qu'on a pas entendu et je
parle pour elle mais ça doit devenir un
symbole pour tous les enfants qui sont
harcelés à l'école parce qu'un enfant le
principal il est garant il est garant de
l'épanouissement et de la sécurité d'un
enfant quand il fait la source d'oreille
il n'est pas à sa place c'est pas la
fonction qui doit incarner on a
l'impression que c'est vraiment une
mafia à l'éducation nationale oui c'est
terrible c'est exactement ça il se
couvre les uns les autres plus personne
ne parle il y a une chape de plomb moi
ce que j'espère c'est que l'enquête
administrative très honnêtement j'y
crois pas et je n'y crois pas j'espère
que la justice là ira au bout